I don't feel like I'm taking crazy pills
anymore the 11th circuit has ruled
against Donald Trump in the Mar-A-Lago
classified documents case and it is a
Beatdown now because today is a day that
ends in why that means this channel is
here to explain what all of this means
because try as I might to get away from
Trump he just keeps inserting himself
into the most interesting legal cases in
the country so strap in for an
explanation for why judge Cannon might
have ruled in Trump's favor initially
the court of appeals is not going to
suffer any fools so let's start with a
recap of what brought us to this point
on September 5th 2022 judge Eileen
Cannon who was controversially confirmed
to the bench after Trump Was Defeated
for re-election authorized the
appointment of a special Master to
conduct an independent review of some 11
000 documents in some 1800 items that
were seized from Mar-A-Lago pursuant to
a search warrant judge Cannon also took
the extraordinary step of temporarily
enjoying the government from reviewing
and using the seized materials for
investigative purposes pending
completion of the special Masters review
or further order of the court in other
words judge Cannon's ruling Force doj to
Halt its criminal investigation of
Donald Trump until the special Master
completed his work though she did allow
the office of the Director of National
Intelligence the odni to continue its
classification review and or
intelligence assessment of those
documents now the doj swiftly appealed
judge Cannon's ruling to the 11th
circuit that is the court of appeals
that oversees judge Cannon but it also
separately petitioned judge Canada for a
partial state of her ruling it went back
to her to ask her to partially stay part
of the things that she had ordered now
in that motion the doj argued that judge
Canada's injunction risked irreparable
harm to Natural security by interfering
with the government's criminal
investigation enforcing disclosure of
these classified documents to a special
master and the doj further argued that
it's simply not possible to separate the
doj and the FBI's criminal investigation
which was blocked from the intelligence
community's assessment which was allowed
to continue as a result the doj argued
that the order had created confusion in
the executive branch and disrupted
intelligence agency's ability to assess
any damage to National Security for
Relief the doj requested a partial stay
of Judge Cannon's order that would allow
the FBI to use the 103 documents marked
as classified for further criminal
investigation and not require the
disclosure to the special master and on
September 15th judge Cannon rejected the
doj's motion and in her ruling judge
Cannon refused to accept the
government's argument that Trump could
never assert any privilege or poverty
interest on the documents with
classified markings those are property
of the government judge Cannon also
refused to accept the government's
contention that the documents marked as
classified are actually classified or
contain extremely sensitive information
that could harm National Security if
disclosed judge Cannon then formally
appointed judge Raymond Deary to lead an
independent review of the Seas materials
then after Trump and the doj submitted
two names to be appointed as special
Master judge Cannon agreed to appoint
judge Raymond Deary who was one of
Trump's picks to lead an independent
review of the Seas material she further
directed judge Deary to prioritize
review of the roughly 100 documents with
classification markings with the goal of
completing the review of all the
documents by November 30th 2022. now
we'll talk about this later but Trump
may live to regret this whole special
Master Gambit and especially regret
agreeing to Deary as the special Master
but the doj then appealed the denial of
the partial stay to the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals so let's talk about
this particular decision from the 11th
circuit now legal experts attacked judge
Cannon's ruling on mass as legally
unsound and ripe for being overturned
however there was some concern that the
11th circuit would let judge Cannon's
injunction stand after all the 11th
circuit is a relatively conservative
court of appeals with Trump having
nominated six of the 11 active judges on
the circuit and recent history shows how
some Trump appointees like judge Cannon
herself have been quite unpredictable in
their particular rulings but in a
unanimous opinion issued on September
21st the 11th Circuit Court of Appeals
granted the government's motion for a
partial stay in a strongly worded
29-page decision the three-judge panel
made up of two Trump appointees and one
Obama appointee ruled that judge Cannon
likely aired as a matter of law by
exercising jurisdiction to quote and
join the United States use of classified
records in its criminal investigation
and to require the United States to
submit marked classified documents to a
special Master for review now this
decision was procurion meaning that all
three judges equally supported the
opinion and as a result the justice
department was no longer prohibited from
investigating the documents marked with
classified markings that were seized nor
would it be required to share those
materials to the special Master for his
independent review but it's not just
that the 11th circuit granted the doj
it's requested relief what's so notable
about this opinion is how it reads like
a complete repudiation both the legal
reasoning behind judge Cannon's order
and some of Trump's more specious
factual claims now in deciding whether
to Grant this day pending appeal the
court of appeals evaluated four factors
articulated by the Supreme Court in the
nken versus holder case first whether
the stay applicant has made a strong
showing that he is likely to succeed on
the merits two whether the applicant
will be irreparably injured absent a
stay three whether issue into the state
will substantially injure the other
parties interested in the proceedings
and four whether the public interest
lies and on every single point the 11
circuit I did with the doj to find that
the stay pending the appeal was
justified now for the first Factor the
doj demonstrated it was likely to
succeed on the merits of its claim under
the Richie analysis now when a person
seeks return of sees property in a
pre-indictment cases those actions are
governed by Equitable principles whether
viewed as based on federal rule of
criminals procedure 41g or the general
Equitable jurisdiction of federal courts
that's according to the Richie case and
under the Richie case when evaluating
whether to intervene pre-indictment
courts assess four factors pursuant to
Richie which we talked about in our
prior video One whether the government
displayed a callous disregard for
constitutional rights and seizing the
items at issue to whether the plaintiff
has an individual interest in and need
for the material whose return He seeks
three whether the plaintiff would be
irreparably injured by denial of the
return of property and four whether the
plaintiff has an adequate remedy law for
the redress of his grievance now under
all four of the Richie factors the court
of appeal found that the doj was likely
to succeed on the merits of its claim
namely the judge cannons order blocking
the criminal investment education and
turning over classified records to the
special master was an abusive discretion
that was made in error now the panel
noted that even judge Cannon found no
callous disregard for Trump's
constitutional rights and neither party
contested this finding and the court of
appeals pointed out that this alone
should have been enough to end the
District Court's inquiry quote the
absence of this indispensable factor in
the Richie analysis is reason enough to
conclude that the district court abused
its discretion in exercising Equitable
jurisdiction here now it's basically
judicial lawyer speak for telling judge
Cannon politely that her entire analysis
was flawed from the very beginning now
this is a factor-based test but
basically the court can almost never
exercise his Equitable jurisdiction
without the presence of callous
disregard for constitutional rights and
in this case it wasn't even close but
for the sake of doing a complete
takedown of Judge Cannon's opinion the
court of appeals continued now for
example while judge Cannon was open to
Trump having a potential property
interest in classified materials the
11th circuit was skeptical that Trump
had any property interest in them at all
Quote for our part we cannot discern why
plaintiff would have an individual
interest in or need for any of the 100
documents with classified markings
discussing the law of classification the
court explained that access to
classified information is only allowed
if a person has a need to know the
information or if the current
Administration has waived this
requirement but as the court of appeals
noted Trump hadn't provided any evidence
that either of these things had happened
quote plaintiff has not even attempted
to show that he has a need to know the
information contained in the classified
documents nor has he established that
the current Administration has waived
the requirement for these documents and
even if he had that in and of itself
would not explain why plaintiff has an
individual interest in the classified
documents the court of appeals called
Trump's suggestion that he Declassified
these documents of red herring because
declassification would have zero effect
on the character of the document and
would not explain why he has a personal
interest in them as many legal experts
have noted Trump has repeatedly claimed
on social media and in interviews that
he Declassified the documents but Trump
specifically avoided making these claims
in a Judicial setting supported by
what's the word
um evidence that's it no evidence
whatsoever and the quarter appeals
noticed quote the record contains no
evidence that any of these records were
Declassified and before the special
Master plaintiff resisted providing any
evidence that he had Declassified any of
these documents now what the court of
appeals was referring to was just days
earlier Trump's lure specifically
refused the special Master's request to
provide evidence that these documents
were Declassified claiming that doing so
would force Trump to quote disclose a
defense to the merits of any subsequent
indictment and in fact they're
absolutely right and it would be
entirely prejudicial to disclose a
defense to an indictment but those are
post-indictment arguments not
pre-indictment arguments like what we're
dealing with right here but they should
probably talk to their client about that
because he keeps going on TV and locking
himself into specific defenses that
actually are not particularly good
defenses at all go figure but at any
rate regarding the third Richie factor
of irreparable harm to Trump judge
Cannon had argued that he could be
potentially harmed if the classified
documents were not returned based on one
improper disclosure of sensitive
information to the public to the United
States retention and use of privileged
materials and three the stigma
associated with future prosecution but
the court of appeals explained in
meticulous detail why all of those
arguments were 100 wrong for starters
the whole reason the government was
investigating the documents was to limit
unauthorized disclosure and Trump has
not asserted attorney-client privilege
over classified document so there can't
be a harm to his privilege there either
and as to the final Richie factor which
asks whether the plaintiff has an
adequate remedy in law for the redress
of his grievance well the court noted
that Trump has a remedy law he simply
has chosen not to invoke it the court
explained that Trump could file a rule
41g motion to get the documents back but
he hasn't but even if he did Trump quote
has not identified any reason that he is
entitled to those documents So based on
the four Factor Richie test the doj
demonstrated it was like succeed on the
merits but returning to the ncen
analysis the court of appeals held that
the United States would suffer
irreparable harm it judged Canon's
injunction was not partially State
finding the government's National
Security review is inextricably
intertwined with his criminal
investigation the 11th circuit explained
that allowing the order to stand would
create a chilling effect on National
Security basically it's not good for the
government when it cannot control
extremely classified documents and to
illustrate this the court noted that
officials Who oversee both National
Security and criminal investigations
into classified information might be
forced to choose between doing their
jobs and facing contempt charges and
with respect to the third and Ken Factor
the doj demonstrated irreparable harm
while Trump had not demonstrated
irreparable harm the court reiterated
that Trump does not have a possessory
interest in the documents at issue so he
does not suffer recognizable harm if the
United States reviews the documents he
neither owns nor has a personal interest
in nor the court affirmed is being
criminally investigated itself a
substantial injury to justify a state
quote bearing the discomforture and cost
of prosecution for Crime even by an
innocent person is one of the painful
obligations of citizenship that is of
course according to the famous Supreme
Court case of cobbledick versus the
United States and finally regarding the
public interest Factor the court noted
that the classified documents contain
information that quote the unauthorized
disclosure of which reasonably could be
expected to cause exceptionally grave
damage to the National Security the
public naturally has an interest in
ensuring this does not happen however a
national security assessment can only be
done if the government is allowed to
review these documents which under the
current injunction couldn't have
happened and having found the balance of
equities overwhelmingly favored the doj
the court of appeals granted the motion
for partial stay of Judge Cannon's order
pending the entire appeal now
essentially the court of appeals
eviscerated Canon's order regarding the
classified documents and all of its
underlying logic but here the doj's
appeal was very narrow probably for
strategic reasons the doj only appealed
the order regarding classified documents
that basically narrowed the focus of the
court of appeals on the classified
documents issue to ignore everything
else but the upshot though is that the
rest of the special Master order remains
which for reasons I'll explain in just a
moment is kind of hilarious at this
point but let's talk about what happened
next with judge Cannon and the special
Master judge Cannon responded to the
partial stay the following day by
modifying her order appointing the
special Master judge Cannon revised her
original order by excluding the 100 odd
documents with classified markings from
the special Masters review deleting the
requirement that the special Masters
submit interim reports and
recommendations to the court throughout
its review and striking a provision
requiring classified documents under
review to be made available for Trump's
Council for inspection under the special
Master supervision and this might be the
11th circuit's last word on this issue
and it may never get to the Supreme
Court because according to many
respected legal analysts like Steve
vladic at the University of Texas Trump
can't ask the entire 11th circuit to
re-hear the appeal on bunk because the
judge has basically removed anything
that was objectionable the same thing
goes for the Supreme Court and that same
day special Master Raymond Deary
released his good case management plan
for his review of the Mar-A-Lago
documents now in this plan he asked
Trump's legal team to state by September
30th whether they believed any of the
seized items were incorrectly described
by the Justice Department's 11 page
inventory list and the judge also asked
Trump's legal team to State whether they
claim any of the items on the inventory
list were not in fact taken from the
premises Trump has repeatedly claimed on
social media and in interviews that the
FBI planted evidence when they searched
Mar-A-Lago claims that his lawyers have
specifically not made in court probably
because it requires evidence and
subjects you to sanctions instead
Trump's legal team asserts that they
can't affirm that the government's
inventory is accurate without first
reviewing the season's materials but as
to Trump's out-of-court claims of
planted evidence judge Deary is asking
his legal team to in legal speak put up
or shut up and because Dairy is not
putting up with some of the same
nonsense that Canon did it seems like
Trump may come to regret pushing for
this particular special Master the
impact of the 11th circus ruling was
immediate and not limited to Trump's
case the same day judge Canon to fight
her order a trump appointed federal
judge cited the 11th circus ruling to
deny Mike my pillow lindell's motion for
the return of his cell phone by the FBI
Mike Lindell who you probably know has
propagated increasingly bizarre
conspiracy theories about how the 2020
election was stolen and that he can get
Donald Trump reinstated as president as
being investigated by federal
authorities in connection with the
breach of Colorado County's voting
system his phone was seized at a Hardy's
drive-through which isn't legally
relevant it's just I think very very
funny and bizarrely hours after the
court of appeals ruling Trump went on
Sean Hannity to vent about the variety
of legal troubles that he's facing like
the New York attorney general's civil
fraud action against Trump and three of
his adult middle-aged children that was
announced earlier in the day I actually
thought that they would never bring a
case and she brought it and when the
conversation turned to the classified
documents Trump once again claimed he
had Declassified the documents Trump
claimed declassification procedures were
essentially optional telling Sean
Hannity that as president he had the
power of declassification
with his mind if you're the president of
the United States you could declassify
just by saying it's Declassified even by
thinking about it and legal experts
weighed in and it should come as no
surprise that no the declassification
processes are not optional and
precedents cannot declassify them with
their mind and in addition to producing
a new psychic Presidential Power to
Hannity's audience Trump also speculated
the fbic's documents from Mar-A-Lago
because they were looking for Hillary
Clinton's deleted emails were they
looking for the Hillary Clinton emails
that were deleted but they are around
someplace
yeah I also don't know how that makes
any sense whatsoever but it's not
helpless for all those lawyers making
terrible terrible arguments and the
former president they can quickly get
their brains back to functioning
correctly with a logic or Math course
from today's sponsor brilliant brilliant
is an online learning platform for stem
that replaces lecture videos with
Hands-On interactive lessons brilliant
is for Curious Learners both young and
old and experienced and professionals
students and those who are not studying
anything anymore you can quickly learn
to Ace your high school or college math
course or just learn stuff that you
always wanted to learn one of my
favorite courses is all about logic
something we haven't seen a whole lot of
coming out of Florida these days but
Brilliance logic courses cover liar and
Truth teller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day well at
least most lawyers but Brilliance
statistics and finance classes are
equally good you will love them as well
brilliant lets you learn by doing rather
than just listening to hours of boring
lectures learning through doing is
scientifically proven to be the most
effective way to master any new skill
the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve so you can sign up and start
learning for free today by clicking on
the link that's on screen right now the
first 200 people to sign up will get 20
off their annual subscription so by
clicking on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description you'll
get 20 off your subscription to
brilliant plus clicking that link really
helps out this Channel and after that
click on this playlist over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court